[Music]
welcome back our listeners to a free
publicly available episode of the pill
pod
it's uh one sec it's number 149 it's our
Halloween episode um only one month
late I am joined by my hosts lib Vic yo
lib Vic I like it that's new lib Vic
Eric Tate hello did someone in the
Discord make that up or no I did to
distinguish you from our guest I like it
who is every time we talk about
figurative language or literature we
need him it's lit Vic AKA let's see if I
can get this renan pronunciation right
Victor
hu you got it okay it's Victor lit Vic
from from here on out follow please
follow him on Twitter so that this
episode is worth his time he's at like
100 just like bump that up a little bit
it's Horatio Victor very literate
sounding we're not we're not counting
though no worries um do you post
literature discoveries on Twitter like
what is the lowdown on literature
Twitter like yeah good question lit twit
yeah here and there sometimes sometimes
there's a manuscript that you know gets
people excited about something or other
or like there's an interesting kind of
like film adaptation so sometimes yeah
there's news in the literary circles but
yeah it's just general interest stuff as
well CU as you've seen sometimes we talk
about film sometimes we talk about
literature in our discussions here so I
guess today we're going to be doing a
little bit of both but I'll I'll let you
kind of uh set the scene pills all right
I won't be saying much as I neither read
nor watched the assignments for today
because I wasn't planning to be here for
today so if you want my uh very tasteful
and well thought through opinions on
Netflix shows sorry sorry about this
one you ever seen any other shows like
that and do you have you ever watched
any of the other Mike Flanigan shows or
just missed this one I watched the Hill
House part one and so this will lead
into my first and perhaps only question
we watched the spin on the gothic horror
show the House of Usher which is based
on the works and work by Ed Gren Poe of
the same name
um but just to kick it off with a
general question so Netflix kind of
likes this Gothic horror Vibe maybe
because the Hill House one did pretty
well but Victor lit Vic Victor can you
give us a bit of a stage for Gothic
horror Literature Like was it was it a
big thing I think it was like a
newspaper thing originally or like a
short story format and what are the
social conditions that produced it in
the first place yeah for sure so for
that you'd have to go back even a little
bit before Edgar Allen Poe we're talking
the early 1800s almost late 1700s with
uh novels like uh the castle of at Tonto
by Horus Walpole and kind of just it's
sort of an offshoot of Romanticism which
is a term more people might be familiar
with in terms of kind of a focus on
emotions kind of passionate um
relationships melodrama not just
Romanticism in the sense of romance but
really a sort of emphasis more on
passions and emotions as opposed to the
r ISM of the Enlightenment right so
that's where you start with Romanticism
kind of reacting to the Enlightenment
and then we get Gothic fiction which is
sort of a sub genre of Romanticism and
gothic fiction which is a term we still
have today in genre fiction sort of
relates more to Notions of sort of the
the darker elements of Romanticism the
supernatural Madness you know the
typical associations with castles and
Dark Knights and vampires and monsters
and creatures like that this all kind of
starts in the early 1800s late 1700s
with authors increasingly sort of
looking at these sort of more genre
fictions as a more respectable way to
talk about questions of subjectivity
questions of um man's relationship with
nature there was a growing uh Trend
towards urbanization and greater people
moving away from the countryside towards
cities during this time which had a big
impact in terms of both how the
romantics and Gothic writers started to
think about well what is our
relationship with nature how do how do
we conceptualize you know living in
cities or living in the countryside and
all this stuff kind of gets wrapped up
in a growing interest in stories of the
supernatural of the Exotic of you know
dark medieval histories and castles and
forests and things that really people
had no longer had access to that they
were increasingly removed from because
they now lived increasingly in cities so
that's sort of where gothic fiction
started and where it got its um growing
sort of popularity from and one kind of
neat thing to note about it is that
originally it was called Gothic almost
as as a term of denigration because it
was Associated so the actual the Gothic
architecture itself which is sort of
based off of or associated with goes
back to the Middle Ages and it's the you
know the kind of cathedrals that were
being built in medieval France and stuff
like that and Gothic architecture itself
was a denigratory term to kind of just
to refer to how UNC and vulgar this sort
of architecture was because it was
associated with a group like the Goths
which were you know the marauding
vandals from ancient times so Gothic
architecture itself was kind of seen as
not being respectable for a while and
then of course now we look at Cathedrals
as being these incredibly beautiful
buildings and everything but that's
where gothic fiction itself gets the
name from so because I was about to
actually I was GNA ask if Gothic
architecture predes the literary style
so it does that's cool just like
postmodernism bab that's a great
question yeah because that would go back
more to the Middle Ages and gothic
fiction so often deals with kind of you
know neomedievalism and looks towards
again Cathedrals and castles and these
kinds of dingy ancient or medieval
environments to sort of tell their
stories so that's just kind of the
lowdown on how gothic fiction sort of
got started and how we get to somebody
then like Edgar Allen Poe writing in the
US whose audience would have been even
more interested in you know these
Fantastical stories about far off places
or you know murders and mysteries from
Europe especially because increasingly
they were living again they were living
in cities they were they didn't have
access so much to
the sort of historical or natural um
Landscapes that these stories often
dealt with but um Eric I know you're
also a a fan or you have some interests
in this genre of fiction is there
anything else that you think is worth
noting just to sort of set up this
miniseries in terms of Gothic as a
fiction I mean in a way Gothic
literature is right there at the origin
of the modern novel really because you
kind of have I guess I guess you have
Cervantes writing maybe in the 17s
Century but then then Horus Walpole is
probably the first Gothic literature
writer um I think Fuko thought it was an
Radcliffe contemporary of wpes but
they're both really famous writers yeah
and and it was part of this sort of it's
interesting that about literature news
because you know people hunting for
manuscripts and stuff this was like a
big Renaissance thing people would be
going into churches and trying find old
you know ancient works that have been
lost and and sort of revive them
translate them whatever and that's how
the first Gothic book was uh Horus
walpole's castle of vanto was
presented with the narrator pretending
to actually be like an Explorer who's
found this ancient Italian manuscript
and has translated it for us and then
Horus Walpole released another version I
don't know how so so many months or
years later and sort of revealed ah that
was actually just like kind of a prank
that was like a conceit and so there's
this pranky element to Gothic fiction
sometimes anyway where it's
written and it's almost like you know
like edar Allen Poe writes like the
great balloon hoax or something like
that and and it's hard to tell if it's
real or not real or like it it kind of
confuses that boundary between like an
author making something up and like this
being a real Discovery some ancient
mysterious text that has been brought to
you from yeah it's got all these sort of
the darker side of of romance in that
sense of romantic
literature I thought it was that's just
interesting I think because the show
really does this it kind of does like is
what's happening real is it all in this
guy's head or is there really a
supernatural thing like it kind of does
it looks like it's going to do the
Scooby-Doo moment where it's like oh it
was all fake F but it never really goes
that far and and so I think that kind of
interesting storytelling is is pretty
endemic to gothic fiction I know that's
interesting I noticed that too in like
as someone who is a little bit more
literarily illiterate like I don't read
as much nearly as much as you guys do um
when it comes to literature but you know
when I was watching the series at least
I I I definitely picked up on that thing
that Eric said exactly where I really
wasn't sure what was going on it kind of
reminded me of American Psycho which
actually have read the the book as well
but the movie also does a really good
job where you really are left wondering
like okay how like did he actually kill
anyone or was this all just [__] that
was going on in his head you know is
this entity a real person but it it did
seem like I don't know how oh yeah we
probably should have said spoiler
earlier too by the way because we're
definitely going to spoil [__] right so
like oh that goes without saying when
when you know we we oh yeah if you
haven't watched the show yet then yeah
you need to not listen to this you go
watch stop what you're doing pause this
episode and go watch 8 hour of the show
read all of the short stories it's based
on do your homework and then come back
and listen or exactly whatever you feel
like we're not gonna and some people
don't mind spoilers but there's the
warning well let's put it this way our
host the esteemed Bill master has
neither read the stories nor seen the
show I think so there you go this is a
sacrifice I'm willing to make is to have
the stories I haven't read on the show
ruined for me to put on a good show yeah
exactly so I don't know how much more we
want to talk about the series I mean I
know like as someone who didn't know
that much going into it like I've I've
been a fan of uh Mike Flanigan I think
is his name all of his Miner like his
horror miniseries it started sort of
with a house of uh The Haunting of Hill
House which was very scary I thought
they did a really good job on that one
and then there's the one that takes
place in the British Countryside like
blind Manor I think it's called and then
yeah I really liked the hill house yeah
that was great fly Manor was was pretty
good yeah and and did you not like the
one about the house user was great
midnight mass was the one right with the
with the vampires yeah yeah that was
[__] cool I I enjoyed that one it
wasn't so much weaving together of
stories you really get that sense of the
weaving together of all these different
narratives I like the style that
Flanigan has I I I've liked all of his
work and then I kind of heard oh he's
like adapting some Edgar Allen Poe story
and it didn't it wasn't familiar to me
so I I kind of just watched it and
didn't know the only part in the show
where I was like oh that's clearly Edgar
Allen PO is they kind of throw in these
moments where the main act the main
character is reciting like poems from
that I recognize yeah the
Raven Annabelle Lee and I have to say
like so I recognize those and I and I
realized right away oh this must be from
Edgar Allen Poe and for me I have to say
it felt a little
hamfisted uh to just throw those in I
don't know what you guys thought but I
felt like it was just kind of like there
and I didn't know what it was doing
maybe we we can do our best to be
generous to the showrunners and
interpret uh perhaps the the the subtle
connections that they've made with Po's
short stories but yeah at least on the
surface they they name each episode
after one of his stories the characters
names mostly come from Ed Gren po
stories and and poems so Annabelle Lee
tamarlane rodrik Usher of course and um
much or at least some of the plot lines
are shall we say Loosely inspired by
some of the Grizzly murders in po
stories yeah like little bits and pieces
of plots exactly yeah so um yeah they
all Echo something in po but it's never
sort of
wholesale yeah it it really just sort of
sets up I guess you could say I mean you
know like a post Cinematic Universe
where oh there's there's this guy and
this character and the Black Cat from
that story and it just but really to
build its own distinct story right like
I I wouldn't call it an adaptation yeah
I mean even the name right the the the
fall of house Usher the story itself
very like very minimally resembles the
show like there's rodri Usher Yeah like
like dupin's not in that story but gets
thrown in there the short story has no
details about like a about like a an
Empire right like a corporate Empire
whereas the obviously the whole story is
like about a corporate Empire and its
fault maybe we can just start by
considering then how does the show like
what is the show's main plot line what
is this story about as far as the show
goes and then see how much if any of
post stories can we kind of see as being
more Faithfully perhaps preserved or
adapted in the overarching story of the
show so yeah as as as you mentioned uh
lib viic um I'm glad you chose such
distinct names for
them that's gonna clear up so much
confusion thanks pills hey I for one I'm
never going to confuse
them over the the this this the show
kind of sets starts off with the death
of all these children we don't know how
they've died yet but um rodri Usher has
buried his La the last of his children
and we are we kind of find out how
corrupt this family was how each of the
children died throughout the course of
the series and the I guess the the sort
of framing narrative is Usher's longtime
Nemesis this detective extraordinaire
he's a I think us attorney in the show
but August dupan who is a famous po
character he's basically the the first
modern detective of modern detective
fiction he's the one interrogating Usher
in his crumbling derelict home you know
what happened to your family how did it
come to this and then Usher kind of goes
through the story of how each one of his
children died but is there anything
anything else I guess guys that you sort
of would think of in terms of the
overall Narrative of the show it's
probably the most appropriate title
because that seem that's pretty much a
description of the plot it really is the
fall of of rodri Usher and all of his
children one by one and there's that
Supernatural sort of Supernatural
element of of you know they met this
woman named Verna which is an anagram of
Raven in a bar and she sort of cursed
them right she's sort of predicted their
future slash sort of cursed them slash
they sort of made this oath themselves
voluntarily um but it was just sort of I
mean I guess this is kind of endgame
stuff but it was like you know all your
kids are going to die basically you're
going to see all everyone else in your
family die and then and then be the last
one it's sort so it's like sort of the
it's almost like a an ancient myth kind
of driven thing the prophecy where
you're you're going to die don't know
exactly how but we know it's going to
happen and now here's the interesting
part how cuz the you know the show opens
up with newspaper articles about the
deaths of all the kids and so you know
okay this is going to be told out of
order and we're starting with the frame
narrative which is after the action and
then we're going to go back through a
load of flashbacks which are mediated by
the conversation that dupen and rodri
are sort of having which is like the
frame narrative well there it seemed
like that that whole aspect of it struck
me as just that classic myth of like the
the making a deal with the Devil right
it's like you you know you have uh you
know do you want to make sure that you
have wealth for for the rest of your
adult life but the cost is going to be
that like oh you're going to have to
watch all your children die basically
yeah and and the fall of a powerful
family that's what we love right we we
love to see powerful people fall from
grace a old very old appeal and that's
where the show's modern Focus kind of I
think really comes into view because
yeah aside from the interest in
Celebrity culture and billion the
billionaire class and things like that
there there there is this satis in sense
of this kind of being like a morality
tale of these rich pharmaceutical types
getting their come UPS you know kind of
loosely sort of probably based off of
actual families like I think the the
Sackler family is is one likely
inspiration the people who ran oxyc
continent and things like that and the
idea of the people responsible for the
opioid crisis especially in the US kind
of having some sort of divine Justice
serve to them at least in the show
through the figure of this mysterious
woman Verna who uh doesn't seem to age
she's present at all the times during
the shows kind of you know the Rodrick
Usher's life and she seems to be the one
who as we noted both rodri Usher makes a
sort of deal with the Devil with her to
begin with and then she keeps coming
back throughout his life and his
children's lives and sort of also
judging them interestingly and and sort
of giving them a chance perhaps to
redeem him themselves but usually just
staging very elaborate ways to murder
them all so yeah it wasn't clear to me
that she actually was giving them a
chance though like I think like weren't
there certain moments where it actually
seemed like she was explicitly making
sure that they died like like even with
Prospero right she said you can you
should stop this you should stop this
party kind of gave him the choice but
maybe like knew he wasn't going
to yeah it's true with that one it kind
of seemed like she did but then in other
ones like wasn't there other ones where
she you you see her like explicitly like
creating the conditions where they're
going to die like like maybe with the
with the orangutang is that yeah she
didn't really stop but she sort of told
her you can't go in there right like she
was if the family wasn't so each family
member was just so pushy they just want
what they want and this person can come
up and be like you're gonna die if you
do this they'll be like [__] you who are
you to tell me and then they just storm
past like it kind of just shows how
horrible each individual family member
is because they don't listen to this uh
future seeeing ghost's advice which any
anybody would if you saw a ghost that
could tell the future you'd listen to
their advice viice right not if you're
an usher of course you just listen to
your own voice and nobody else's because
all the ushers are such [__] I mean
I think in the end it kind of it even
suggests that maybe rodri Usher was
doing all of this like it leaves it open
right even the party that Prospero
through right all the you know all the
staff mysteriously walked out right
before the Big
Moment the lady was seen on the cameras
like other people have seen this
mysterious ghost woman but it's still
kind of unclear whether this is because
roderick's telling this story to dupen
you can't forget that this is all just
sort of dramatizing so this these
elements could just be rodri story and
you know he's the one who kind of [__]
his sister up in the end too it wasn't
the ghost so you're kind of left
uncertain whether Supernatural things
really did happen or this is just a
psychological iCal breakdown because he
does have dementia he says right away so
it's like a psychological Thriller and
that and this is gothic fiction right
psychological Thriller disturbing is it
real is it not real yeah I think on that
note too the the way that this series
was sort of shot in um I mean there were
there were definitely moments of kind of
you know psychological drama but it's
generally shot in a fairly cold clinical
modern kind of way so you you're led to
sort of believe or to take at face value
what you're actually seeing is really
happening it's not very stylized in in
terms of sort of seeming to maybe have
an unreliable narrator or anything like
that so I think that's also what what
why some of the events seem quite
shocking because they they just sort of
happen so bluntly and literally in front
of us and um that's one distinction that
I I definitely kind of felt with um with
Po's Original Stories where so much of
what he's saying in the stories is
shrouded in all these levels of mystery
and he has so many stifling descriptions
of every single step that the narrator
takes or anything like that so it's an
interesting contrast with the show
itself where we actually see things
presented very clearly very much sort of
happening in in real time and I'm just
wondering if um I mean for anybody
anybody who look also looked at the
stories if you got a sense of that
difference in tone or the vibe of the
show being quite different in that way
from the the stories themselves in the
show I think what's clear is like those
events happen but I think the part where
you're where maybe there's a little bit
of play is like well was it really this
entity or did he go insane and maybe
like do that although that there's no
indication that like Roger user actually
did any of those murders I don't think
but like there's at least some
indication that like there's a like
there's all this discussion of him
having some form of dementia right where
he's imagining things so that's I think
the indication but you're right that the
way it's shot is like very like literal
and clear and you see these like
horrible things happening to people it's
a matter of translating yeah lit lature
onto screen and we have lots of examples
of Gothic I mean one of my favorite you
know Gothic sci-fi you know Blade Runner
that's a great example of kind of
gothic fiction that's been sort of
translated onto the screen and so those
elements of of lots of Darkness lots of
like light dark shots confinement
interiority um being buried alive
psychological Terror like these are
these are stylistic and thematic
elements that need to be translated onto
the screen so like what I was saying
before like with the castle of Otranto
being presented as a translation like
you can't really do that with a film on
Netflix you can't be like Netflix found
this ancient Greek film in a in a church
it doesn't the the the medium itself
doesn't work for that so you know it's
kind of all fake you know you're
watching a performance here they have to
translate that in a different way and so
the frame narrative kind of maybe steps
in there and and helps add that sort of
meta uncertainty back into it a little
bit but yeah it's all about translating
those different stylistic aspects you
know life and death right an obsession
with death and dying for instance right
that's loud and clear being buried alive
that happens in the first episode right
you know the the House of Usher the
short story right his his sister his
twin sister is buried alive she he inmes
her before she's dead it turns out and
she comes back and strangles him and
it's a creepy story very atmospheric
very slow paced but very you know very
much like um
descriptive and so you saw that twice
right in the first episode you know we
see the mother
Eliza Buried Alive by the
children and then comes back from the
dead quote unquote and then
strangles that old guy that was her boss
and sort of oppressing the family and
then that sort of same thing is repeated
in the end so like that is from the post
story right but it's stretched out into
this broader it's it's that's why I said
he kind of takes bits and pieces and the
whole thing is more like an amage than
an adaptation because it's got its own
thing going as well especially with the
pharmaceutical subtext it's not like
there was a company running
Manufacturing absin in the 1800s which
po wrote a story about so it that
definitely a much more modern element
but I I think yeah one of the stories
which it's most closely at least
grounded or start starts with is the
Fall of the House of Usher itself
because that's one of Po's actual short
stories and that seems to be the
foundation that it then throws all these
other kinds of subplots and everything
into that and I I think it might be
helpful to just sort of think about that
story just a little bit in terms of
seeing where the Usher characters
themselves come from and to what extent
if any there is a connection in terms of
the the show's take on this character of
Rodrick Usher and the original po vision
of it and I just wanted to maybe also um
briefly look at one of the examples of
POS writing because it it stands in
stark contrast with the certainly what
we're used to as like modern writing and
modern fiction as you were just
mentioning Victor so this is from the
description of the uh the character of
rodri Usher from the post story and how
he's also the the narrator is also kind
of describing the House of Usher itself
like the physical building where this
character lives at this point so from
early on the narrator kind of presents
the scene and this is in Po's story now
he says
quote uh I had learned too the very
remarkable fact that the stem of the
Usher race alltime honored as it was had
put forth at No period any enduring
branch in other words that the entire
family lay in the direct line of descent
and had always with very little trifling
and very temporary variation so Lan it
was this deficiency I considered while
running over in thought through the
perfect keeping of the character of the
premises with the accredited character
of the people and while speculating upon
the possible influence which the one in
the long lapse of centuries might have
exercised upon the other it was this
deficiency per apps of collateral issue
and the consequent undeviating
transmission from sire to Sun of the
patrimony with the name which had at
length so identified the two as to merge
the original title of the estate in the
quaint and equivocal appalation of the
House of Usher an appalation which
seemed to include in the minds of the
peasantry who used it both the family
and the family Mansion end quote so that
gives you an idea of just how much more
dense and layered POS writing is where
he spends so much time kind of building
up a mood and an atmosphere with his
word choice and just really kind of
sinking you into this feeling of dread
and NeverEnding sentences and the kind
of Gothic atmosphere that Eric was also
talking about and that's that's a a big
part of the feeling too is is this
ancient bloodline this mysterious
ancient wealthy family and which is
extra weird because he was saying there
they have no branches like it always
goes father son father son like there
there's never like a sister who has a
son and then that goes off and creates
another family line no the like the
branches of the tree always kind of die
and it's just a it's just a a trunk
basically and and so it already kind of
has this weirdness to the family like
there's something wrong with this family
there's
something I don't think they're thinking
genetically wrong but like almost cursed
like an ancient family curse right and
so they're mysterious they're like in
the countryside like you really really
get I mean if you if you've read any HP
Lovecraft right he's he's always
describing people like this like part of
these ancient inbred now they use these
terms in the 20th century after the
Eugenics movement but like you know it's
that same that vibe that ancient Vibe
and then the fact that the house and the
family are sort of the same thing that
the House of Usher refers to the family
line and it refers to the location the
the house itself that they live in the
Mansion is a weird cuz then the whole
thing's going to collapse at the end and
kind of metaphorical like at the end of
what at the end of that movie the the
Poltergeist or something where the house
just goes and
vanishes and it's it's it's very
symbolically overdetermined that way as
as you note Eric where we have the house
itself the building the family line as
the house and it's funny that you use
the word inbred because I think that's
one of the interpretations of the short
story at least where there's not a lot
of plot really it's just about kind of
this this ancient figure this character
rodri Usher he's paid a visit by the
narrator he's in a state of melancholy
for whatever reason people are in
Melancholy in post stories and he has a
sister meline Usher who looks
suspiciously like her brother like
rodderick and the narrator kind of notes
this and the sister is very sickly and
she actually dies shortly after but the
idea seems to be perhaps that either
they're twins or there's been some sort
of incestuous relationship over the
years where this family is really kind
of just they're keeping it in the family
in this way they don't want to kind of
you know spread their bloodline Beyond
brother and sister so I don't think that
really carries over too much into the
show but it shows you at least how in
post time people thought about these
decrepit you know corrupt ancient
families and how much they didn't want
to share any of their power even if it
meant kind of just marrying their
brothers or sisters they they would just
sort of hold on to everything until the
last breath so the internal dynamic
between the the bastard children and the
non- bastard children is a bit gets a
bit of that right because the bastard
children are very self-aware and
capable and the like fraud they jokingly
call him one of the say like the non-
bastards is just [__] useless so
there is a bit there is a little bit of
that translated kind of obscurely like
perhaps the the purebred ushers are
extra [__] up whereas the bastards are
just sort of a little bit [__] up yeah
I was going to say also that uh I think
the one way in which the suggestion from
this short story about the incestuous
relationship it's because I didn't read
the short story when I watched the show
and when I watch the show it's funny
because I did feel like the closeness of
the brother and sister did seem like
kind of weird like how close they were
like it didn't it definitely didn't
cross the line where like closer than he
was with his wife
yeah exactly like it didn't cross the
line where you thought that they were
like having sex or anything but like you
definitely were like wow like they
really are like a package deal like
those two like they're together all the
time they make decisions all the time
like it was like so I think like maybe
that's the way that um Mike Flanigan
kind of took that interpretation and I
feel like he just decided to make the
brother and sister characters like
really like unusually close or like kind
of like a team deal like a package deal
where they're they're literally scheming
and making decisions all the time
together right and they even schemed the
murder they schemed the murder of his
boss right like at work together which
does that part come from one of the post
stories or did I miss that oh yes that
that is one of the famous Grizzly dark
Stories the the The Cask of a monato oh
right where it's it's a it's a very
quick story it's actually set in
Renaissance Italy where during a
Carnival festival there's this uh
unnamed narrator I think monserat
perhaps is is his name and he lures his
great rival Fortunato note the name for
into his cellers promising to give him a
cask of this fabled wine of called am
monato and he lures him down there into
the deep dark dank catacomb of a wine
Celler and he sort of traps him at one
point and he starts to inom him with
bricks Brick by Brick just like in the
show and yeah the this guy's looking at
him like in horror what are you doing to
me why are you doing this and the
narrator just just keeps doing this and
the whole idea is like it's for some
unknown reason Revenge Revenge is all
that you need yeah and the motivation is
unclear and the show gives you the
motivation right it's to it's to take
over the companies they they murder the
and of course the the sisters involved
in the show right so it's not just like
one person and they do it together
they're complicit and that's that's a
great distinction too because the in the
in the shows there's less ambiguity
there's in terms of their motives yeah
there's less of that mystery or dread of
like you know why is this person killing
someone else like in the post stories
often there there's no motive really
it's just this sort of you know
heightened sense of almost Madness that
sort of per pervades the the psychology
of some of these characters but in the
show it's very clearly done for profit
and I think that's the more modern
emphasis where you know you have these
ruthless wannabe billionaires whatever
new money and they're just doing
everything they can to acquire the
company to acquire corporate power and I
think that that yeah that that's an
interesting sort of I guess contrast
with how the original family in the
Usher Story by po is just sort of this
old world wealthy corrupt aristocracy
and they're you know living in this
ancient Mansion whereas in the show
they're more of you know this this
upstart pharmaceutical company who kind
of got to where they were by ripping
people off and ultimately you know
causing the opioid crisis but I think
that tells us a lot about the different
kind of villains that we have in mind
when it comes to the the wealthy or the
upper class these days it's interesting
though that in the show in a way they
are the rightful family right because
they're like the bastard children of the
head of the company right so like there
is that that kind of double play where
it's like yeah they're new money and
they're taking it but I don't remember
them actually saying explicitly kind of
like that they're doing this because
it's actually rightfully their right as
the real children but I feel like that's
the implication in the background
because you kind of know that they're
actually his children like the the the
CEO's children but they're they're
bastards right and then that's where
that theme of like well I don't know if
it's a theme but like that's where that
through line comes where he's obviously
going to keep all his children because
he's not going to do what was done to
him as a child right where he's not
allowed into the family fortune because
he's a bastard you're right that all the
post stories there's a kind of horror to
them because you just like don't know
why it's just like these horrible things
happen it's like and maybe some of that
has to do with like the horror of kind
of like the possibilities of modern life
being surrounded by all these people and
you have no idea what any of them are
capable of right so it's like kind of
expressing that that that potential that
possibility and yeah definitely like the
this more modern retelling and and kind
of synthesis of all these stories is
much more of almost premised on a
rational actor model of human sub
subjectivity right it's like they're all
doing something for a very narrow
specific reason right they make they
they take this deal with the devil
because they're like well yeah maybe
it's worth it or like kind of they want
to change the world right exactly so so
that's that's thees they're going to
change the world or kill everyone in the
process I think that this also comes
back to I guess um kind of competing
views not just of human nature but also
of the natural world itself because that
that that's one of the things that um
definitely in the 19th century with
Romanticism and gothic fiction and stuff
like that the idea was that nature it
was like decidedly anti-rationalist the
argument was you can't interpret nature
you can't understand everything in the
way that Enlightenment thinkers seem to
believe that they can it it's that you
have to be sort of a little bit more
humble about man's or you know
humankind's ability to understand the
world past a certain point and that's I
think represented in a lot of post
stories even in a famous poem like the
Raven where you know the bird shows up
in the narrator's chamber and the he he
keeps asking the bird why are you here
what are you doing you know do you have
any relation to my dead wife Lenor and
the Raven just keeps mocking him never
more never more there's no way to fully
understand why the Raven's there what
the relation might be with the the
narrator's wife or anything like that so
it's it's it in in a way it's a failure
to read those kinds of symbols it's a
failure of interpretation you can't
understand the darkness past a certain
point and I think that's something that
it's it's a very kind of Gothic impulse
to sort of say past a certain point it's
just nature and Madness and the
unknown and I guess the way that maybe
Flanigan thought that he was preserving
this is well you don't really know who
this entity is but at the same time it's
like pretty clear like I felt like in a
way after watching it I kind of felt
like oh yeah I understand what happened
they made a deal with the devil and then
like it's like okay it's clear right and
you're right that maybe there's
something I don't know if you were
saying that there's something lost but
it does feel like it's not in the same
Spirit of kind of like not really
understanding why the happen I wouldn't
say necessarily it's lost I I would say
that it's sort of shows us how we have a
different conception of you know what
our monsters are in the modern world or
what the villains are because back then
again it was the sort of almost the
longing for the mysteries of Nature and
the sort of unknown Supernatural realm
and I think nowadays it's it's more like
we have a sense of we know who the
villains are at least or we like to
think we know you know certain members
perhaps of the billionaire class or this
the scheming corporations or whatever
like that and but there still seems to
be a sense of which they're beyond our
reach somehow there there's that
frustration that's where the sort of
horror of these kinds of stories comes
from because they're just so insulated
from the the consequences of their
actions and it's sort of the Common Man
will never be able to sort of strike
back and take revenge in the way that we
see actually takes place in this
miniseries so yeah that that that says a
lot about sort of Shifting ideas of um
the kind of villains that we sort of
like to have in our stories I think
these days as opposed to when po was
first writing his own uh
fiction I wonder if it would be useful
to because we kind of already talked
about The Cask of a mon [__] I forget
what the
what is that again Amon BR
am about how that fits in maybe it would
be useful to just kind of go through
okay like what are the other um kind of
like overt uses like what where are all
the stories so I know that you asked us
to read uh the cast of am monato um and
then you also asked us to read uh the
mask of the Red Death uh the murders uh
in the rorg and The Fall of the House
Usher so we kind of talked about The
Fall of the House Usher already how
there's not much
just this thing that happens I really
enjoyed the murders of the room and it's
funny because it's only like one little
small part of that that's in the show
right but like that's a good one the
detective story itself is great it's
actually delightful I would even just
call it like I I really enjoyed that one
um first first detective
stories yeah I mean you could really
tell I remember we we did we did the
perin letter on this podcast I don't
know probably like more probably like a
year ago or maybe more and uh that one
we talked about how cuz one also has
dupan right this detective character
yeah I think there's three of them that
have dupan exactly and and I would say
that in this story more than the pein
letter at least I felt I felt like in
this story the kind of inspiration for
Sherlock Hol really came through more
because like a lot of the story I want
to say maybe even a majority of it it's
just kind of him going through the
different reasoning right kind of like
reasoning out kind of like eliminating
you know what what what seems impossible
and then whatever remains you know
however improbable must be the how did
the murderer Escape how was the person
shoved halfway up the chimney that would
take like four strong men to do it and
like and then at the end it's like oh it
was an escaped ape oh it makes so much
sense now but it's still then you think
about that and you're like wait a minute
that's [__] up it's not like a nice
sort of everything makes sense after
Sherlock Holmes ending it's like a a PO
ending where it's like didn't make me
more comfortable but it was a good story
and then I guess in the show there was
an orangutang murder right wasn't there
it's like what which part is that yeah
yeah at the r at the r morg well the the
joke the place they jokingly called R
morg but they called it the ru Zoo
because it was the test center where
they would do the animal testing oh
right the animal testing right okay yes
so that was again like very
minimal except for the ape the ape
murder that's rumor definitely but
there's no
Detective out of those like just dupan
being there and the whole frame story
being almost like an interrogation or a
confession which is a device that I
don't know if po used that sort of
confessional retrospective device too
much um it's more we're sort of getting
like installments of a story or you know
like dupan comes in and then he tells a
chunk of what he's figured out and then
he leaves and then we hear some more
stuff and then dupan and we get to hear
some more of what went on and and I mean
there's a bit of that in how po actually
writes we do often get it this
confessional tone even in po stories
because the narrator themselves or the
narrators themselves are telling the
reader how brilliant they were in
committing a murder or how they got away
with it until the very end when they're
caught by the police or but so that's
often where the confessional stuff comes
from I think even for the show is po is
interested in the psychology of the
criminal and how they then sort of
justify their actions to the reader or
to whoever their audiences and then sort
of working through that and seeing how
it all sort of falls apart by the end
because that's the classic po ending as
you noted Eric where things seem to be
wrapped up sometimes but there's still
this unsettling ease of you know what
just happened there's a sort of uncanny
element of things not being quite right
like with the murders in the rorg where
the murderer is an orangutan it's it's
it's not even a human there's there's
this weird un you know disconnect which
is quite unsettling actually that this
wasn't a person
but then it gets you thinking okay so
what how were apes or orangutans
considered when po was writing this you
know what was the relation between the
human and the animal at that point this
is still a little bit before Darwin's
sort of theories are widely published
but still you see that there there
there's there's always kind of
interesting threads you can follow up on
in terms of even how he stages these
crimes and what they're sort of meant to
get the the audience to think about in
terms of you know an ape having done
this and not a human but what does that
mean then in terms of where the animals
fit into this hierarchy and everything
like that it's quite
interesting but I mean in in the short
story it's sort of framed as well of
course it's the Sailor right who who who
was captured this orangutang brought it
back and really was just looking to make
money off of it right in a way like that
was kind of the main motivation in the
short story that like the reason he had
an orangutang is because he bit on an
expedition I think to like Bali or
somewhere in like the Indian and you
kind of get the impression that at that
time it's like you know having these
exotic animals it's like you know
obviously they probably weren't
regulated and it's just like if you have
one it's probably get a lot of money for
it right which of course nowadays I feel
like you'd read that and it's like well
people can't have a rangit tanks like No
And nowadays the focus and the anxiety
is more on animal testing and oh we we
have to be more careful with how we
treat apes or chimpanzees and how close
they are actually to humans and it's
sort of we are the villains in in this
story where you know look at how cruy we
are treating animals in the miniseries
take on it but it's interesting how at
least 200 or so years ago when PO is
writing about apes they're these
terrifying creatures which could be the
murderer in a story it's yeah s it's
also funny that like in the short story
he he's like oh lure the the person who
owned the ape by putting out an ad right
that'll like that'll say like don't
worry like I have your ape like come get
it and it's just like funny from modern
modern ears or you know or modernized to
be like oh well like you you can't just
like unpro say like I found your
orangutang like come get it it's just
like that's like it's just like so weird
well how many people owned orangutans
back then I think the person would know
when they saw that poster it was meant
for them yeah exactly but now there
would be all these bureaucratic
questions about like well are you
allowed to have this orangutang right
it's like and obviously from reading the
short story you can tell that it's like
totally unpro it's just like oh yeah
like just it's your it's your property
like it's no no issues right and you're
right that this the Moder the the show
it's funny that their Twist on it is
like animal testing right which is kind
of like deep concern like in a way like
exposing the the horrible acts that we
commit uh on
animals man is the Crest Animal yeah
that that that's the focus really on you
know the more modern perspective on the
human an animal relationship and stuff
that's a good point yeah so what one of
the other stories I guess was uh the
mask of the Red Death yeah I mean
there's so many stories really each one
of the episodes is Loosely digging into
some of the PO lore and kind of using
that as its sort of structure but uh
yeah I guess mask of the Red Death is
was another interesting one because it's
uh it's actually not said in the modern
world it I think it goes back to the
Middle Ages in uh the story at least is
about Italy during the plague the black
death and how um these Aristocrats this
Lord called Prospero hint hint he's uh
he runs this masquerade ball at some
Abbey or estate he has and he closes it
off very deliberately to the outside
world to the lower classes to anybody
who might be you know carrying the
plague and he just wants to sort of
party there with his you know upper
class Compadres and party yeah yeah and
then of course there's the mysterious
stranger who shows up and he the robe is
pulled off of this stranger to expose
who he is he's wearing this red robe
crimson red and it seems to be that
there's no one under the robe except
it's the plague itself that has managed
to sneak into this masquerade and then
of course everyone there dies yeah so
that's the post
story and then of course and I guess
that's where the entity comes from right
we get the adaptation yeah so maybe you
can talk a little bit more about how
that works in the show yeah I mean in
the show obviously right this is the
scene I would say maybe the most
horrifying scene in the show arguably
right it's like one of the sons I think
he might be the youngest or second
youngest it's kind of a a [__] who
just wants to party all the time oh
definitely the youngest one yeah he's a
bit of a [__] EG and is just like wants
to party all the time and [__] Orgy Club
Orgy Club and just like open an orgy bar
a whiskey [__] bar and his name is
notably yeah Prospero or Perry in this
version the young socialite and
basically like there's a whole
discussion about the company of how like
they have all these facilities that are
being investigated and one of them is
like this manufacturing warehouse
that's abandoned they're not using it
and there's kind of an implication that
there's something hidden there that like
they haven't been allowed to go and
inspect it I guess like and then so
Prospero decides oh I'm GNA [__]
throw a rave there just like you know
have a great time like a masquerade Rave
yeah and like he goes and and he finds
that there's I guess these these like um
I guess like showers on the ceiling that
that that they just assume is like the
sprinkler system right we like it is the
sprinkler system I think and he's like
oh sweet like at the Crescendo of this
Rave I'll turn on the sprinklers and it
must be connected to this this water
tank on on the roof right and it's like
oh like at
midnight which isn't actually uncommon
there's a lot of places in the states
where where they they store water tanks
on the roof notably I think New York
City has like water tanks on the rubs um
of places but but that wasn't water in
this that definitely wasn't water
exactly so like at midnight strikes and
then and of course this entity shows up
and and kind of talks to him and is like
you know you don't have to do this and
you know some question about whether or
not that's like a sincere attempt to get
him to stop or just or maybe even making
sure right like another way of reading
it is well this entity knows that all of
these kids are ship eggs who want to do
what they want to do and want to rebel
so if I tell them not to do the thing
it's going to make sure he does or
something right like that could be a way
of reading it but um but yeah and then
of course at the midnight strikes and
then and then it's obviously this evil
Corporation was storing some kind of
strange toxic chemicals in this tank and
everybody in the party gets like burned
their skin peels off and like they all
like turn into [__] just melted into
a puddle of people yeah exactly exactly
it's pretty shocking but but then in the
in the in the short story I guess it's
not so much a chemical right it's other
that rather that they all like succumb
to a
disease yeah it's essentially a version
of the black death and that that's
what's interesting is again when when PO
is writing about this stuff the focuses
more on threats from the supernatural
world but when the show adapts it it's
no this is a man made kind of you know
virus it's something that it sort of
comes back and affects Prospero now in
the upper class and they sort of get a
taste of their own medicine almost like
literally but um it's otherwise the
structure is kind of quite similar to
the story where there's this big party
like a rave a ball and everyone there
who thinks they're safe is actually they
they find they can't close themselves
off from the outside world however you
want to kind of read that or interpret
it there's a sense in which they can't
isolate mes from the rest of humanity
yeah just those plague party things you
know that goes back to like bachio de
camaran right like the right you know
the the wealthy people going off to
avoid the black death but uh in uh I
guess in the modern day yeah it's much
better to cast that as like exclusive
nightclub parties because that's what
they're all doing now they're you know I
mean that's the that's the sort of
fantasy of it all is that you just get
to spend all your time going to fancy
Raves all over the world with really
expensive booze and it's it's a very
different kind of of segregation of the
upper classes but you know with the
black death we would be talking about
well look at the resources they have
everyone else is just kind of left in
the urban streets and not really able to
remove themselves like that but this
party uh yeah the the Black Death came
for them anyway or the Red Death in this
case yeah and in some ways though with
with Co and everything we're not that
far from the you know plague discourses
and stuff like that as well because
we've also we know what it's like to be
in quarantine like quarantine I think is
actually an Italian word originally
which referred to how you you had to
spend 40 days outside of the of the
town's Harbor before your ship could be
clear to enter because they wanted to
make sure you weren't carrying you know
the black death or the Red Death or
whatever so there's a lot there's a lot
of ways in which actually we can relate
quite a lot to the medieval experience
of kind of hunkering indoor and waiting
for the plague to pass and um that's
yeah I think this version of the story
is done quite well in the show because
it shows you how um at least in in this
case the the rich and the famous and the
wealthy can't isolate themselves from
you know whe whether we understand it as
as a plague or death perhaps more
symbolically there's a sense in which
this catches up to everyone that you
can't buy this level of privacy or
isolation from these fundamental forces
yeah I think it hammers that home
there's consequences right this is the
you know the yeah the wealthy people you
know they go through their lives
destroying others and no consequences
stick to them right but this is about
that everything has consequences and it
sort of a symbolic
Justice it's kind of sad though because
you know Prospero is told you know
you're the you're the like most bastard
of all the bastards you're the youngest
you have to try the hardest to prove
yourself and that's what he's doing but
he's coming up with these stupid
childish ideas like like clubs and bars
and all he wants to do is party and so
you're kind of torn it's like this guy's
just a privileged prick but also has all
these disadvantages but he's rich but
he's just trying to make something of
himself in this highly demanding family
atmosphere but like [__] this guy but I
mean pretty pretty epic party but oh my
God like it's it's it's a very
conflicting I mean the characters are
jerks but you can also kind of identify
with their struggles a little bit before
I even knew what was going to happen it
was very obvious I was like oh that's
that's going to be bad is when he's
planning the party and he notices the
sprinkler and he's like oh it must just
be connected to the tank on top which is
filled with water and you're just like
just so weird like the assumption that
he makes and it's like I don't know I
just it's like maybe a nitpicky but I
just didn't buy it I was like of course
if they if that was little drop of water
fell on his phone or and they would have
tested it too right it's like it's like
if you're going to have a big party and
you want to make sure that it's
connected it's like it just didn't make
sense that it's like it must be that and
therefore we're just going to do it for
the first time when everyone's there
like not that they would actually think
that it was toxic chemicals but more
that you would have tested it to want to
make sure that it works so like that's
just like a weird behavioral hole for me
where like it was just one of those
things in in a show where I'm just like
that wouldn't
happen that reminds me though cuz you
know you know that that huge oversight
of not checking the T thanks that was
actually a pattern when you see that the
ushers tell people to do something for
them and those people do it for them
right and that's often where things go
wrong is because the ushers expect so
much from other people right and those
people are afraid to say no to them so
Prospero has his two poor party planner
lady friends that he uses to do and he
just tells them to do stuff and they're
like uh is this going to work and he's
like it's what I want so yes it's going
to work same thing with the animal
testing [__] and the drug stuff that you
know Usher was like this needs to move
to human trials right now and then you
just get this picture in your mind of
drugs being pushed through you know the
testing processes and data fabrication
and all that like you don't say no to
the ushers same thing with that guy
who's trying to replace the cat that
he's just drunkenly murdered and the
lady in the store it's like actually
this cat's spoken for but like all these
ones are going to be put down at the end
of the day if you want one of them he's
like I must have that one and then [__]
goes hits the fan again he goes nuts and
the cat is involved in that too yeah
you're right like it's it always seems
to be like the ushers tell someone to do
something for them they're so afraid to
say no that they will do whatever it
takes even if it's a ridiculous idea and
they will hide the fact that this idea
is not going to work like this
investment is going to yield nothing and
they'll hide that from so like it's like
the wealthy people want the stuff the
ushers want the things they want and
they don't know that it's unrealistic
and improbable at best that's a good
point it's gonna hurt a lot of people
that's a good point because you're right
that I I forgot that in that in that
scene he does just tell his minions to
go be like I want you to hook the
sprinkler system up to that to that tank
so like I guess it's plausible to think
well they just did it and then didn't
check it I won't take no for an answer
but at the same time it's like how do
you connect it to the tank without
seeing that the liquid is actually going
through like I don't know I just still
was just I they might have known and
just done it they might have just been
like [__] this guy but I guess they
would have left if they really knew yeah
exactly it's almost a a critique of how
much the rich are able to delegate these
kinds of responsibilities and just rush
things through and have things done for
them and when that backfires as it does
so spectacularly here in this episode in
this story we kind see I think what the
intention might have been at least in
the sort of the the morality play aspect
of it where you know some a character
here was clearly acting in a certain way
and their death sort of corresponds to
their crimes or their sins in a way and
that's a running theme through the whole
show where it's not a coincidence how
each of these siblings ushers children
how they all end up dead it's sort of
loosely related to their crimes or their
sins yeah no for sure I think that's
well that was that was the uh the mask
of the Red Death I think the the the
next there's so many yeah I mean was the
Black Cat one where this black cat sort
of torments him
psychologically but again it's like the
black cat it's hard to tell if it's real
or if it's just some kind of paranoid
delusion that this guy's having because
he's grieving and on so many drugs yeah
and in the story The Black Cat from uh
Edgar Allen Poe of course it's it has a
similar setup where the narrator has
this um he's he has this affinity for
animals and among his other pets there's
a black cat and his wife sort of thinks
that cat's a bit sus you should give it
up and the narrator he doesn't see it
that way he likes this cat but then some
kind of Madness comes over him he
actually starts to grow distrustful of
the cat and at one point he gouges one
of its eyes out just in a fit of passion
or something or rage yeah paranoid yeah
and then long story short events
escalate um the cat is killed but then
the the the narrator's house burns down
mysteriously the next night and
eventually another cat shows up which
looks just like the cat that he killed
only it has some sort of a white belly
it's a little bit different and when the
narrator tries to kill this cat as well
the wife kind of tries to get in the way
and save the cat so he just kills his
wife as well no problem and then he
buries the wife to sort of you know keep
that out of the Harm's View and um
eventually the police show up they're
like okay your wife is missing what's
going on and the narrator is very
satisfied with himself kind of like in
The Telltale Heart that there's no way
he can be caught here you know he's
hidden away the the corpse of the person
he murdered but there's a noise that
comes from behind the walls and all of a
sudden the narrator realizes oh no I
left the cat with my dead wife's corpse
and the cat gives away where uh the body
was so it's a little bit like The
Telltale Heart but it also kind of gets
back to this question of just how symb
olic is this black hat business like how
much is this in the narrator's head how
much is it their own paranoia being
projected out and I think that that
comes across a bit in the in the show as
well with the black hat episode and I
think that old conceit that you know
guilt will sort of tear you up from the
inside the mind will give itself the
guilty mind kind of gives itself away
there's sort and the paranoid delusions
when you're trying to hide something you
know that's that's what it's about
keeping things hidden and dark conf
finded places there's a real symbolism
to the to all of these sorts of motifs
right tombs enclosures you know yeah
yeah sealing people up and keeping them
hidden and then it kind of
reemerging almost from the unconscious
right like unconscious guilt seeping
into your conscious life and you're
trying to push it down and and keep it
hidden and say I got this all under
control but really things are falling
apart all around you and then you know
even in the show how do the how do we
deal with this we we denial displacement
projection in the best case sublation
that's the healthy form of of dealing
with h trauma but all the other ones the
ushers are really good at denial yeah
displacement you know the chain of
yelling or projection you
know just it's not my fault kind of [__]
can I jump in here maybe to discuss hor
a little more generally as a genre cuz
horror more generally as a genre at
least in recent years as compared to
when we were maybe teenagers or younger
it seems like the there's a a an attempt
to make horror as a genre relevant which
seems to be you know oh there's a demon
but the demon is actually depression or
oh there's something haunting you but
it's actually the trauma of your
childhood and this one I mean not having
watched it but listening to your
analysis of it it's like trying to put
succession into a horror genre by
killing killing rich kids but the rich
kids are the the kids are dooming
themselves because they're just [__]
so we can't really be afraid of anything
because it's TV and we're over saturated
by images and and all this but putting
the Sackler family in and animal testing
human trials opioid epidemic everything
that you guys have brought up yeah does
this work with the gothic references or
is this like we're going to make horror
a relevant genre again and then just
stuff everything into it it's trying to
put a face and identity on something
that in po like Po's atmospherically
it's always a
nondescript yeah dread a dread from
nature or a dread why is this raven
hanging around or creepy and Atmospheric
yeah that's exactly right that aspect of
the supernatural it seems like they're
trying to make it too relevant that kind
of loses the dread a little bit maybe
maybe we'd want a more straightup
adaptation of Po rather than an attempt
to make Po relevant the fact that you
haven't watched that and just from
hearing our conversation I I I
personally feel like you you did hit it
pretty pretty dead on there like I think
that the show was trying to be relevant
now I will say that I think just
Flanigan in general because he's so good
in my opinion at
making like at crafting those TV shows
that like you're right there are all
those social commentaries but at least
from my memory they're not they don't
feel that hamfisted they sort of feel
like in incidental background facts but
then you're right as all the children
die like it's definitely intertwined
with your feelings about like greedy
rich people so there definitely is like
a social commentary there maybe more
than any of his other shows now that I
think about it because I don't think any
of like the blind man or The Haunting of
Hill House they don't have any social
commentary really like at all like in
that political sense he's really playing
on on what we talked about with bars
that connotational level where you sort
of cap off the the the message with your
own values and
interpretations from your own cultural
upbringing like he's he's I think he's
trading on that right because you have
the sackers and the opioid crisis and
all of that that's clear subtext you
just have General the problematic
billionaires in the world today that's a
clear subtext you know those those sorts
of things yeah are definite
updates trying to yeah make Po into
somebody who has something to say about
current events and and and contemporary
ways of thinking which I think is true
and it's I think it's
valuable um and Mike Flanigan's
obviously just great at this actually
this this this one in particular really
reminded me almost of like you know if
if if dupan is the dark detective story
that PO came up with and Sherlock is the
is the bright one almost the modern day
equivalent would be um the Daniel Daniel
Craig playing Glass Onion Knives Out
Knives Out yeah Glass Onion I think that
was a sequel this one actually reminded
me so much of almost like a a non Gothic
version of that right you have all these
different quirky characters telling
their story to a detective and then we
sort of get to see all of it unravel and
we have to put it all together because
it's all out of order and and you don't
get all the facts in the first run
through each story sometimes and so you
sort of have to you know put new facts
you learn back into the stories you
heard and like the earlier parts that
reminded me of this much more than than
uh even Flanigan's earlier stuff where
you yeah detective investigating wealthy
family mysterious events have occurred
and shocking revelations are to be had
yeah just reminded me of that for sure I
think there's um I'm okay I'm I'm gonna
try to be generous to the show and see
actually how we can maybe interpret it
and see if it does still have certain
elements at least of POS themes in this
regard to answer your question pills
about the question of horror because to
me how horror works could I just phrase
the question cuz my question is actually
a little more simple are we as a 21st
century audience compared to a 19th
century audience just actually too dumb
to be able to cope with a nondescript
existential dread or a nondescript fear
and so it's just much more comfortable
to put a social issue onto it and call
it a day like instead of probing
whatever universality there is to The
Human Condition and the fact of death
everything can just be a morality story
instead I think the dread is still there
and the fact that it's social just says
a lot about how we view our own villains
and monsters in today's age like I said
before so okay back when po was writing
in the
1800s the way horror worked in a lot of
his stories is you have this sort of um
there's a failure of interpretation when
it comes to Nature and the natural world
there's something uncanny in the way
that nature is just so indifferent
sometimes to human suffering and there's
there's like a lack of meaning in many
of the stories ultimately it's like why
did this happen why did the murderer
kind of do this why did why did why is
the Raven there and it's not explained
and that's where the nightmare logic
kind of comes from where there is no
logic ultimately and it's sort of this
failure of meaning in in those terms and
sometimes even the the line between
what's internal and external like you
talked about Eric where you know we have
these spaces and we were're not sure if
we're dealing sometimes with what's in
the narrator's mind or in the world
itself
that line gets blurred a lot so again
that all feeds into the more classic
version of nightmarish sort of horror
and I think where the show maybe maybe
even unintentionally picks up on some of
that is the sort of the the anxiety
around a lack of control that we have in
Modern Life when it comes to these sort
of in obscenely wealthy individuals and
how they're able to sort of get away
with murder literally and run their
schemes and run their pharmaceutical
companies and everything and none of
that is sort of within our grasp as just
ordinary plebs perhaps and how that at
least there's a frustration there
there's a lack of agency which seems to
sort of feed an interest in these kinds
of stories where the villain is now no
longer the natural world but it's you
know these unapproachable impenetrable
forces of finance and commerce and these
billionaires which personify them and
how that sort of Disconnect that's where
the horror comes from so it's much more
heavily steeped in social commentary
it's much more literal it's not a super
natural force it's it's it's a family
but our displacement our lack of control
in relation to these forces that seem to
run the world I think there there's a
lot of anxiety there that's very ripe
for a Horror Story be it this one or
something more modern but we do get to
watch them get their come upins though
right so like the show in a way does
like give the kind of modern
satisfaction of seeing because this
entity like right there's one way in
which seeing this entity this kind of
devil making a deal with the K devil
character as just just being that right
like some kind of like but there's
another way of looking at her as being
like well she's like justice embodied or
something like that right like she's
she's dealing out Justice against like
the rich greedy self-interested kind of
like billionaire class yeah she's almost
like the the not the voice of conscience
but like yeah like the sort of
Revenge almost well again her name is
Verna right Raven and she kind of
doubles as the Raven so it's kind of a
you know when Usher passes out at one
point and then he's looking straight up
and there's a raven sitting on the fence
looking down like remember you made this
deal kind of thing or you know you chose
this path and and here it is now
unfolding it's kind of very fatalistic
in that way right where it's like
because we're we're not used to reading
stories anymore that are like we know
the ending right that ve very old
stories often you know what's going to
happen and the interest is in how it's
told and so this actually dips into a
bit of that where it's like it gives the
ending Mo a lot of it if you watch the
first episode carefully you know you can
kind of see where it's going but
nevertheless it the the
storytelling this is I think Flanigan's
specialty is just you know this complex
multi-layered multi-linear story that
he's able to tell in a very satisfying
way I think otherwise yeah we don't
understand or maybe that's maybe pills
maybe we're not too stupid it's just
tastes have changed a bit and and most
of the uh horror is like now you know
you see ramp up tension ramp up tension
jump scare jump scare jump scare like
that's kind of but this one doesn't give
into that there's there's some jump
scares um but there's not that many it's
more an atmosphere of dread and horror
and paranoia and and uncertainty as to
what's real and what's not real you know
and that is I think those are just
harder and more sophisticated feelings
to deal with that that Netflix and
Hollywood tend to dispense with those
sorts of subtleties but when you get a
good director like that or I don't know
who else maybe they're good writers and
good cinematographers and stuff he's
probably got a whole team anyway yeah
when you can deal with those things then
it works otherwise it's just jump scares
and and creepy monster flicks no he
obviously has a great team because you
notice Mike Flanigan uses a lot of the
same actors too like like throughout all
the shows it's like a lot of the same
actors but yeah yeah I want to say
something to pills' question earlier
because I think that he uh made me think
like this question of you know is our
modern audiences like too stupid to deal
with kind of Uncertain horror and kind
of like what po was doing although uh
Victor you've been emphasizing the way
that po it's like kind of the horrors of
nature is like at least one of the the
sort of themes and like I was just
thinking to myself I was okay like is
there anything that's like relatively
recent memory that kind of takes like a
technological spin but it's just like
pure like you there's just like no Rhyme
or Reason for why and like for some
reason I immediately thought have you
guys seen that movie Cube yeah yeah okay
because that's like a really weird
Canadian movie and it's just like these
people just wake up in these that's like
saw before saw was around yeah I mean
kind of but it's like a lot but it is
but the thing that I think makes it
different than saw is like you never
understand why the thing is happening
it's just like they just like wake up in
there they just wake up in this
technological room and it's like there's
kind of a horror of Technology theme
because it's just like why would anyone
create this building that has all these
traps that kill people they you hear the
characters speculating and the first one
to die was like The Escape Artist yeah
and you you hear you hear them
speculating and like one of them maybe
was like some bureaucrat who helped
build like the outside structure of it
but he had no idea like what it was and
it's and like I don't know that's like
the closest I feel like to giving a kind
of I don't know I don't I feel like I'm
I don't I'm not enough of an authority
on PO to like say that it's like Po like
but at least in the sense that it's you
don't get any answers like it's just
like there's this pure horror it's very
technological and and you never get
satisfaction about like to know why it's
happening it's just like people in a
situation and there's like some over
there's some like you know kind of
Illusion to bureaucrats and governments
creating this and no one really knows
why they did it and then at the end like
you don't really get an answer it's just
like watching these people react to it
this anxiety as well even in po it
definitely manifests itself sometimes
towards technology and urban spaces and
like crowds and things like that for
sure so that is also as I think the
movie that you noted Victor kind of gets
me thinking of Kafka kind of being sort
of halfway between Co and the modern
world where he goes much more strongly
in his details about the sort of
faceless bureaucracy and the nightmarish
logic of Institutions and stuff like
that so I think one other film in more
recent memory that maybe evokes this
feeling of kind of dread that can't
really be placed is um Enemy by Deni vuv
which is one of his earlier films Jake
Gyllenhaal which was actually filmed in
Toronto and it depicts Toronto just
filmed but takes place in Toronto right
because a lot of movies are filmed but
don't take place Toronto is kind of
central because exactly Jake Gyllenhaal
kind of commutes from Tonto to Mrs Saga
and it's seen as like this nightmarish
hellscape of condos and a yellowish he
works at UTM right yeah yeah so and I I
won't you know spoil the movie but
that's it's in one of den Lin's less
well-known films but it I think that
captures pretty well the sense of
unresolved horror the kind of dread of
living in a sprawling City where you
don't really know anyone else and you
ultimately Jake Gyllenhaal's character
he almost gets displaced from his own
sort of identity in in really weird ways
so that element of horror is still
around I think in a series like this one
Fall of the House of Usher we have a
more literal take on what's Happening
where people are dying and it's for
pretty clear reasons but in terms of the
atmosphere of horror yeah there's
perhaps films which have placed a
heavier emphasis on sort of doing more
with images and and less with uh with
with words and I wonder if maybe that's
also a byproduct of the fact that this
is kind of a miniseries it's not just
like a movie you there seems to be this
this Reliance on dialogue which is much
much more prevalent I think in Netflix
Productions at least it's it's telling
more than showing at times that's true
yeah so maybe a a couple things that
could have been done differently but all
things considered for myself who hasn't
watched it and anyone else out there who
hasn't watched it is this a watch or
skip I liked it I think it's worth
watching I think I think Mike Flanigan
just in general is pretty I think has
shown himself to be a reliable
showrunner to just make good stuff I
think we mentioned that like the
Midnight Club was maybe his weaker one
but that seemed like it was maybe more
targeted at like a teen audience or
something it's it had a very different
feel I don't know did either of you guys
I think maybe Eric you mentioned you
watched like a bit of that but didn't
you did you watch it at all Victor or no
no no I haven't seen in any of his other
work but I know midnight mass is quite
highly recommended midnight mass is
excellent I think they're all quite
excellent and I would call this I would
say that this is as good but you know as
we talked about it it's funny this
conversation I think made me like it a
little bit less because I think like I
realized that the social commentary like
I I already felt a little bit weird like
it's funny you haven't even seen it uh
pills and maybe you just said that
because we mentioned it but it really
did feel like succession like it had
very succession Vibes um and in a way
like I felt like that that kind of took
away from from some of the more like
horror elements of it but I still would
definitely recommend it yeah I'd say so
like I really loved Haunting of Hill
House bwood was was a was a decent
followup this one was this one was
really good though if you're especially
if you're a PO fan yeah you got to see
this it's great like Hill housee is kind
of pretty rewatchable too because it's
almost like you just want to it all fits
together so nicely it's almost like you
want to go back through it all just now
seeing how it all fits together with
this one it h i think everything hangs
together a little more Loosely it's not
as it's it's not
as yeah it's not as seamless but it's
still really well done Hell House really
gives you that feeling where you watch
it the first time and then you're just
like holy [__] that thing that happened
earlier you're like I got to go back and
like see in terms of like horror
miniseries like it's it's hard to
imagine something
better yeah this one I want to go back
through it because I know I missed
references and I know I miss I probably
missed like Easter eggs and things but
I'm not always super concerned about you
know finding all the getting 100%
achievements on spotting all the Easter
eggs kind of thing but when it's like an
interesting storytelling technique that
I feel like I didn't quite get like you
know in the in the hill housee right
that you know the bent neck lady and
that scene where she just it just runs
her through every single scene that she
was a part of in the whole series and
you're like oh my God that's how it all
fits together
and it just like kind of blow there's
that like mind blower moment there and
you didn't really have that in this
there's no sort of yeah there was no
like oh it all kind of fits together now
makes sense and here's how everything it
it all just kind of is what it is but it
it was really well done at the same time
and uh yeah it it's definitely a
worthwhile show if you have any interest
in this kind of genre in some ways even
more for what it sort of says about the
people who made it and the the audience
because that that's part of the interest
here where you see okay what are the
monsters that people respond to nowadays
where how do we Define horror and who do
we associate it with and this show is
very revealing in terms of what it sort
of shows how would you adapt Po in a
more modern context so for that alone I
think it's qu it's it's quite
interesting and and worth checking out
and um pretty much each of the episodes
as we discussed references a post story
so if there's one or two episodes that
you thought were especially kind of
interesting check out the post story we
haven't talked about all of them here
there's too many to go into and see if
that's a kind of style that you also
kind of maybe Vibe with so yeah I would
definitely say check it out if you get
the chance if you haven't seen it
already by the end of this
episode yeah I mean it's already I'd say
my my one complaint is that I wish there
was more dupen like I I hate that they
included dupen but he was so peripheral
like I wish he was there was you get you
get one little maybe two one little
glimpse of his amazing deductive
skills in the flashback scene when young
dupen is in the house with Rodrick and
his then wife getting kicked out and he
basically just reads their life off of
the room it's like you have two kids one
of them's sick there's honey you've been
using it as like a home remedy I can
tell you're living hand hand them out
and you just see that that shining of
the
dupan powers of observation but then
then it goes away and and it's all a
kind of confessional like I wish they
didn't add the detective but make it
into a retrospective story like one or
the other like make it happening in time
but dupen is finding stuff out and it's
not from Roderick Usher's perspective or
kick the detective out of there because
he's such a cool character he deserves
way more screen time and moreal and just
decide okay I'm going to make it from
the perspective of the bad guys right
that classic thing right it's from the
perspective of the anti-heroes right I I
think it's only a matter of time until
Netflix or some other company Minds the
August dupen franchise possibilities
because he's again he's the original
Sherlock Holmes in some ways there
there's there's a lot of potential there
for a movie or a miniseries or something
that's a bizarre choice to make mix
those two up because there's the Greek
style where you get the prophecy at the
beginning so you already know the end
but the literature Trope of the
detective is that the reader figures out
the mystery at the same time yeah it's
yeah well the wheels are coming off the
show guys nothing to see it is I mean I
think Eric that's such a good point
because I did feel like the way that
dupan was depicted in the show it's
like he's like he's sitting in the chair
being like and and he's talking to rodri
Usher
and he's he's not quite depicted as a
fool but he's definitely depicted as a
little clueless like he has no idea like
why those things happened maybe it's
because he's some sort of a positivist
in a sense that like you can figure out
everything through deductive reasoning
so like the fact that Supernatural stuff
was included obviously that's going to
stump a dupah who's a dup who's who's a
who's a you know um a positivist to some
extent so maybe that's the explanation
right it's like he's obviously not going
to be able to to to to to um anticipate
supernatural phenomena yeah I mean other
than that that that's the thing that
bothered me everything else is great I
think and I enjoyed spotting the
references very much very much fun yeah
can you accuse this series of doing
cheap cheap fan service like the uh the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that'll drop
in the comic references for no reason
just so the real heads know that the
makers know I don't know how far Netflix
is going to get with that when there's
probably like 10 poads and two of them
are already on this podcast yeah like
the pit in the pendulum where the
swinging pendulum is slowly gonna cut
the person in half I mean how much I was
like is there a Maelstrom I don't know
how much of an audience there really
would be for a kind of Po fan service
past a certain point but yeah hopefully
and like I said before too I just
thought that I I did feel that the that
when Roger gusher just breaks out into
poetry it just felt a little a little
hamfisted to me but yeah Annabelle Lee
was his sort of old wife it's
interesting though because um you know
that that poem pops up in Lolita and
Annabelle Lee and Lita is like his his
prototype Lolita he was in love with
this girl Humbert Humbert was when he
was young of an appropriate age they
were both young but she died and that
poem was like sort of the centerpiece of
Lolita and and supposedly explains part
of his pedophilic inclinations was this
sort of aborted love of his Youth and
you really get this sense that when
Usher drove off his gold his wife with
the golden heart and that was sort of
his that was his Breaking Bad moment
kind of is like okay he's bro he's
breaking bad now and he's he's he's in
his sister's sort of calculating she was
like the cold calculating circuitous one
and he's the one to just run straight at
the problem but but she's saying that
doesn't work anymore like you can't be
the Knight and just charge every
situation you have to you
know almost be this horrific Insidious
psychopath to like get to to get
anywhere in life and so it's like oh
defer to the genius sister okay that's a
great connection Eric because I think uh
Nabokov originally wanted to call Lolita
the kingdom by the Sea based off of the
Annabelle Lee poem so that was a huge
influence on that story so yeah people
have been remixing PO for many decades
now there's there's always something new
to kind of draw from his
works yeah great well good place to end
I think yeah uh lit
Vic thank you for coming as always yeah
I mean it was definitely a nice break
I'd be remiss to mention that did you
guys all spot uh uh Mark
Hamill what no of course he was like one
of the top five characters I didn't
notice I didn't notice until I looked at
the cast list Pim I was like what no
Arthur [__] I totally missed that Arthur
Pim I don't know why you guys didn't
notice Mark H oh my God the makeup was
so good I definitely did not pick up on
that no that was like holy [__] like Tom
Cruz and Tropic Thunder I didn't realize
till the end it was him holy [__] I did
not pick up on that that is blowing my
mind right now wow okay cool yeah yeah
now that you said it I see it but the
makeup and obviously like Mark Hamill is
known as a voice actor so he also like
Chang there's no Joker Laugh In that one
no like he's he's a prolific voice actor
so it's actually wow that's crazy
couldn't leave without mentioning that
anyway I do always get a weird feeling
using like an audio medium to recap
something from another medium I guess we
do that all the time with with text but
yeah the podcast can't transfer to you a
feeling of dread maybe it can we haven't
tried it like um all right with that
thank you lit Vic give lit Vic a follow
do you have anything else to send people
to or is it just uh the Twitter uh check
out Enemy by Den vov with Jake
Gyllenhaal I can vouch I can vouch
that's my only recommendation yeah I
have no involvement with that movie but
I'm just saying it's it's a good movie
it's super good and it takes place at
UFT
also all right thank you everyone this
has been
149 thank you for indulging us some
literature and we will talk at Youk you
next time
[Music]
later